good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn about how to
not worry about what other people say
over you Brett Barbara you know for me
my career has been awesome
of their public decisions I wish have
the name differently and as I look to
the future that probably the same thing
you know in all phases of life and I
really I don't worry about when people
say it good or bad we would all love
good things to be said about us
assurance nice pick up the paper and
turn on the news and your things are
said about you and that's not always the
case so I really don't pay attention to
it I I really feel like that my
character speaks for itself the way I
played the game left cured myself it's
always been perfect but I'm very proud
of what I have done on and off the field
and that's ultimately that is a the most
important thing is how we feel about
ourselves it's important understanding
that the minute that you start to do
something different the minute that you
start to try to stand up from a crowd
and go do your own thing that's the
minute that you start to get criticized
by other people if you don't do the
thing that your family wants you to do
if you don't do the thing that your
friends want you to do or your culture
wants you to do as soon as you start to
lay your own path and say this is
direction I want to go in and be
different that's when you start to open
yourself up to criticism because people
are one afraid but you're off doing this
thing that's different and it's not
normal and it's unsafe and so we're
going to tear down that person people
are going to be jealous of you saying
well I wish I could go and do that but
I'm too afraid to go do that myself so
I'm just going to stay in like my corner
and just throw tomatoes at that person
people also out of love will criticize
you because they think that your past
should be the normal safe one instead of
going off and doing
that scary thing and so as entrepreneurs
is something that we all will come up
against because by the very nature what
we do we're off doing different things
we're off trying to create in the world
we're off trying to invent something
different we want to change the way
things are done and whenever you stand
out we're going to get criticism and so
as to start I think it's one
understanding that recognizing that
trying to put yourself in that person's
shoes and say listen you know this
person who's criticizing me just doesn't
get it instead of taking it personally
because what happens to a lot of people
when they get that criticism is they
shut down they can't handle it they're
not used to it and so they shrink so
they have this bold goal this bold
mission of where they want to go and
then as soon as humble they tax them
they shrink back down said oh maybe I
shouldn't do that maybe I shouldn't go
for that and so you cancel your own
dream because of other people's
expectations on you I remember when I
made my first believe video I showed it
to somebody who are respected in the
film industry and he didn't like it he
said it was too long and nobody would
ever watch it and that I should cut it
down and he told me that I didn't
understand how the internet worked and I
looked at the video again and this is a
guy who understood the industry it's not
some outsider who doesn't really
understand anything just people throwing
their opinions at you he understood the
industry and I looked at the video again
you know what I just loved it I loved
the video I'm even it was a complete
flop I still had to put it out because
it meant something to me now luckily the
videos did well the video had a hundred
thousand views in the first month but
sitting at over two million views now
the video was the became the best video
that I had on my channel at the time but
not everything is going to work out some
things are going to fail some things are
going to flop on you're not going to
have great results at the beginning of
anything because you're learning a new
skill but what's important to understand
is you need to make a decision at some
point in your life that you're going to
live your version of your life instead
of somebody else's version of your life
because everybody else has a plan for
what you should do and until you decide
to break free and run with your own plan
and deal with the criticism that will
along side it then you're never going to
go off and accomplish the big things
that you have in your so the question
bait today is I'm curious what was some
harsh feedback that you got on your
business idea or in your personal life
that hurts you for a while I maybe by
spreading it here you can release it
release it from your system so that it
no longer bothers you leave it down the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Alfred gondolas Alfred
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word it really
really really means a lot to remain and
I hope you're enjoying the room so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I will see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events Press
[Music]
you don't pay a lot attention to reviews
and those kind of things
well you know you're always affected by
opinion but the more opinions there are
of you me the more I the less I look at
them because I just can't live my life
based upon what other people think about
me so I can't concern myself too much
with what other people think you know
it's just not healthy I don't think I
could continue to do what I do if I was
constantly worrying about what somebody
thought about it if the rest of the
people really feel me as a politician
furthermore bad politicians and I feel
sad or cutting career a cunning liar
politician then of course no problem the
world a son says and the good person
sons a bad person that doesn't matter
some of my own motivation for thinking
is honest cinsay that's it that's
important that's simple Buddhist monks
actually easy but that is you thought
don't care what others are saying if one
say too much praise then at that time
you should think oh I also have the
critics and then one says it did not run
criticism and you should think or some
people praising me this so doesn't
matter too much though because of the
pay much attention in these things are
silly you know how did you ignore all
those naysayers and continue to sort of
blaze the trail of 90 95 % of all new
ventures fail so if you just bet against
all new ventures the odds or 90% that
you're going to be right
90% of the time but you're going to miss
that one out of 110 or 120 chances to
really hit a home run and I wasn't
worried about Tom then they say are
saying it wasn't going to work I just I
just laughed about it because I knew it
was and you worked very hard at it is
well I I wasn't going to let it fail
and even if you read my book it's right
there that which I wasn't going to let
it fail and I'm not going to let dog I'm
not going to let humanity fail to get
rid of nuclear weapons and and and and
and and handle this energy thing I'm
going to keep fighting til til we start
getting it right